hello and welcome to beckmann coulter's
sponsored webinar going beyond cell
counting and solving common problems
faced by laboratories
i'm khalia stallings from beckmann
culture's global public relations and
media team and it is my honor to
introduce to you dr fernando chavez our
scientific affairs director
dr chavez received his md from the
federal university of sao paulo brazil
he is board certified in anatomical and
clinical pathology after his residency
at boston university
he is also board certified in
hematopathology
after his fellowship training at ucla
he has published numerous scientific
articles describing novel utilizations
of data that are readily available from
hematology analyzers
he has been working as a global
scientific affairs director at beckmann
culture since 2010.
today dr chavez will discuss on how
technological advances with beckmann
culture
800 and dxh600 analyzers are bringing
practical solutions to address problems
faced by labs and the clinicians and
helping their patients
after today's webinar you'll understand
how this technology
can help labs achieve optimal patient
care with accurate counting
automated detection of important
morphologic changes
while minimizing workload impact due to
decreased false positive flagging rates
at this time i will turn it over to dr
chavez
please feel free to submit your
questions during the presentation and dr
chavez will answer as many questions as
time permits during the q a session dr
chavez
thank you very much kalia um it's a big
pleasure to be with you today um good
morning or good afternoon in which part
of the council you are so today we'll be
talking about um the the technology that
we have in place in the dxh800 analyzer
um and and i think more importantly just
talking about the technology we will
show to you how this technology is used
to be solving common problems in the
laboratory uh so that you can actually
achieve a better patient care and at the
same time
um minimize workload so we're gonna
start this presentation and first i'd
like to set the stage to what is the
clinical need that we are addressing
with our technology so what what is
hematology really made of and um we will
understand
why um there is a lot more that we
should be doing in the lab instead of
just counting cells which is what we've
been doing for the past 50 years or so
and increasingly as the
laboratory hematology
has has moved away from from the
microscope we also forget are forgetting
the importance of
morphology of the size and shapes of the
cells and that is critical because all
these morphological information can
really give us a lot of important
diagnostic information and we are
missing behind we are almost becoming
sellers of numbers uh to clinicians when
in reality the job of the laboratory is
to be a consultant to be a partner in
patient care
so now we have technology that allows us
to be analyzing the morphology of the
blood at the same time when we are
counting cells and that is really
important because we can detect this
morphologic abnormalities and therefore
we we can prevent a patient who has
changes in cells that can carry
important uh meanings to the clinicians
uh we can prevent this sample from just
being reported out with normal counts
and nobody realizing that this patient
was not really just another healthy
individual doing a cbc account so we're
gonna discuss how the technology works
and we're going to divide this
discussion in two aspects one is the
side of the the
technology how customers can use it and
and they can actually take control of
their analyzer and uh use it to flag
from normalities that are important for
them but at the same time we will also
talk about
um how the technology is deployed also
for the counting of cells because you
cannot forget this instrument
is also supposed to count cells it's not
uh before anything that it's wrote and
in terms of counting cells the major
problems that we have is not really the
counts all instruments our technologies
do a pretty pretty decent job in
counting cells the problem is when do i
have interferences so way too many times
we have the instruments have to stop
they have to flag a sample and a human
being has to go and see what is what
went wrong and and that caused a lot of
increased costs and labor demands on
laboratories and this is really a time
when this is a problematic uh issue for
them so with our technology we are
really uh for the most for a number of
situations where we have interferences
we actually have empowered the
instrument to solve a lot of problems
for the lab without even knowing that
it's happening and then we're going to
see
more in this presentation
now again why is morphology so important
basically when we look at blood and the
microscope imagine that we were back in
1940
or 1945 when when there were no
instruments yet and it had a human being
reviewing the blood at uh under the
microscope he would be counting cells
that is the main purpose of that
activity it will be to be looking at the
cells of the microscope and recognizing
okay this is a lymphocyte it's a
monocyte there's a lymphocyte the
lymphocyte is a neutrophil and i'm
counting them right the technologies of
pathologists but at the same time when i
am counting the cells
i am also evaluating their morphology so
if i see a neutrophil that has very
heavily granulated um cytoplasm this can
carry a clinical significance or if i
see a monocyte that is large and
activated with histiocytic features or
if i see a lymphocyte that is also very
large uh with high low nuclear
cytoplasmic ratio all these morphologic
changes
can they don't necessarily make a
diagnosis but they can have an important
significance
and and just as some examples here the
the images that we are seeing here those
are traditional morphologic changes in
neutrophils that have been well
described in literature for you know
over centuries uh over center at least
um that have been these are changes that
have been associated with bacteria
faction and sepsis so here you have a
daily body in the cytoplasm of this
neutrophil here you have toxic
granulation
where this neutrophil instead of having
just a few pink and purple granules they
have very heavy granulation vacuoles in
the cytoplasm in the lower left and you
have band forms so all these changes are
critical because
we know today that the sensitivity of
the
cellular counts for sepsis and butter
infection is less than 50 maybe less
than 60 for sure so that means that a
patient may have
overwhelming bacterial infection even
sepsis and they may have a completely
normal white blood cell count
and neutrophil count as well and today
this results being reported out of
clinician the clinician is going to not
suspect sepsis that they may even
discharge the patient and the clinical
consequences can be terrible now what is
really really sad is that the
morphologic information that could have
allowed us to reach a diagnosis was
sitting in the blood but we never looked
at it
why because we don't go to the
microscope anymore for example so what
we need now is technology that is
besides counting cells it is also
evaluating the morphology so that when i
have a sample with these changes
even if the count is normal the
instrument is telling me that the
morphology is not normal and i should be
reviewing the sample at the microscope
another example here
i have uh
examples for example atypical
lymphocytes they these are cells with a
very large larger lymphocytes than
normal
much more abundant cytoplasm so the
nuclear to cytoplasmic ratio the nc
ratio is lower and that has been widely
described as a change in viral
infections hyper segmented neutrophils
this is another change that we know is
associated with deficiencies of vitamin
b12 and folic acid which is also also
another important abnormality in the
blood myelous plastic syndrome for
example which is another important
change a disease that uh most patients
who are diagnosed with mds they do not
have symptoms yet you don't want to wait
until they have symptoms to make a
diagnosis and today most of these
patients that are diagnosed by pure
incidental findings basically they do a
cbc for whatever reason and um the cells
counts are very low and you detect these
patients but in reality many times
you may have a patient whose counts are
not absurdly low they are still you know
the borderline low so they don't trigger
as married you and if you don't regress
my review don't go to the microscope you
never suspect that this patient had the
marrow dysplasia
um and you miss an opportunity for a
diagnosis so this is another example of
the morphology the fact that you're not
appreciating morphology anymore and how
we are losing an opportunity to provide
an optimized patient care um to to
everybody who gets a complete blood
content laboratory
so
now that we understand this limitation
how can we address this with technology
we need instruments that besides
counting cells that are also
checking the morphology for us and this
is what we do in bachmann culture uh
hematology so here you have our core
technology which is called
vcs
technology
so these are three different parameters
that we look at in each single cell
and allows us to actually look at the
cell with a set of eyes and it's very
unique to beckmann culture because we
don't actually treat the cells in any
way other technologies will have to
stain the cell with fluorescent dyes
with chemical dyes to know if the cell
is a lymphocyte or neutrophil etc
therefore they can count cells but by
using these diets they are not really
evaluating the morphology
in our technology we don't treat the
cell in any way we just look at it we
look at them and we look at them with a
set of eyes and the vcs car technology
these are the eyes of the dx800
instrument
so let's go and see how that works
the volume is um basically the culture
principle whoever works in laboratories
know this knows this principle very well
basically the volume is is a electric
measurement by impedance where we have a
positive electrode in one side and a
negative electrode in the other side of
the analysis
and and what we will see is that when
you have the factors you have a positive
negative electrode
this basically generates an electric
current in this area and every time you
get a cell passing through the area of
analysis
the cell blocks this electric current
once this electric current is blocked
you have a voltage differential so i can
basically get a milliliter of blood
run it through an area of analysis an
aperture we call it and i can measure
how many pulses of voltage differential
i got and that's my number of cells per
milliliter now
um the impedance the the impedance of
this pose is directly proportional to
the size of the cell so by this coater
measurement alone i can tell that
the size of the cells again size of the
cell is one of the features that the
doctor is looking at when he is trying
number one to count the cells so to
classify this is a neutrophil length of
lymphocyte i have to classify the cell
so that i can count them and we classify
them
based on among other features the cell
size and the same features being
captured with the instrument
the second parameter we look at is the
conductivity basically the conductivity
is like a radio we are throwing waves of
sound
at the cells and on the opposite side we
have a sensor that is measuring how much
sound arrives there
and we know that cells that are more
dense they have higher conductivity this
is the same as if you go
on the ocean or a lake and there is a
boat nearby or a jet ski with an engine
we know that when your ears go under the
water that the sound the noise of that
engine becomes louder to you because
water is a better transmitter of sound
because it's more dense so this physical
principle is the exact principle that is
used in our instruments a cell that is
more dense
can transmit the sound better and as a
result
we have higher conductivity
now how does density translate into
morphology well the nucleus is more
dense than the cytoplasm therefore if
you have a cell who has a higher
proportion of nucleus in its overall
volume then you have a high conductivity
so that's a measurement of nuclear to
cytoplasmic ratio or what we call mc
ratio
the other parameter that we look at is
the laser light scatter
we will hit the cell with a laser
and we have a photo sensor at in the leg
instruments at 45 degrees of angle and
what that will do is it will basically
allow us to
to measure
of that laser how much light was
scattered when the cell passed in front
of this laser and we know that if a cell
has more granules in the cytoplasm or if
the cell has a more a nucleus that is
not nice and round but is more irregular
and divided in multiple lobes these
cells will scatter more light
so as you can see with the laser light
scatter we are measuring granularity of
the cytoplasm and lobularity of the
nucleus with the conductivity we are
measuring the nuclear cytoplasmic ratio
and with the impedance we are measuring
the sum of the volume
all these features
cytoplasm granularity
locality of nucleus and serration size
they are the exact same morphologic
features that a pathologist our
technologist is using to classify a cell
and count them
but they are also the exact same
morphological features that we evaluate
in the blood when we are hoping to
capture if a patient has a change that
could have important clinical
significance like a viral infection when
you see an atypical lymphocyte which is
larger and has a lower
energy ratio or a suspicion of mds when
you have a hypogranular neutrophil with
a fewer grams of the cytoplasm or
suspension of sepsis and bacterial
infection when you have a large
activated neutrophil
so the key point is if we can use these
morphologic features
um
to recognize cells with our eyes and not
only recognize and count them but also
suspect the flag for the normalities and
if the instruments are looking at exact
same features why can't we use the
instrument to also capture and evaluate
this information for us
and how do we do that so we know that we
have now vcs we understood how that
works how do we transform that
into
uh information to be used for um for
the instrument we'll go over that now
now what we do have now in a new
instrument called the xh800 is that we
don't have only one laser light scatter
we have
five different angles of light scattered
and that is important because now we
have seven different measurements
instead of having volume conductivity
scatter we have volume conductivity
lowest angle flight scatter which is the
light scattered at only one degree of
angle and we call that actual light loss
or al then we have lower angle light
scatter which is a light scattered at
nine degrees of angle then we have lower
medium angle light scatter which is the
light scattered at 20 to 49 to 19
degrees of angle and then i have upper
middle angle light scatter
now this is important because when we go
to the next slide we will see that these
parameters are used to plot
cells in a histogram
and the way that we classify cells and
we discriminate slay from cell b is
based on the position of the cell in the
histogram now if i have seven angles of
let's scatter
uh seven parameters with five angles of
right scatter i don't have only one
histogram that i can create i can create
multiple histograms by combining any two
of the seven parameters so i can combine
volume with the conductivity that's one
histogram then i can combine volume with
actual light loss that's another one and
with the other four angles of light
scatter so i now can have six histograms
created by combining volume with the
other six
then i can get conductivity and combine
with the five angles of my scatter
that's five more histograms and four
more histograms etc so i have abundant
new data abundant new histograms that
can be used to isolate and classify
particles and this is why we can avoid
interferences this is the user
morphology to avoid interferences so
let's see how these histograms are
generated and how we are using this
information to both allow for a better
counting without interferences thanks to
the multiple angles of red scatter and
at the same time allow it from an
automated detection
of morphologic changes in the cell
so basically
uh once the volume the conductivity and
the laser light scatter parameters are
measured the instrument will give points
to each of these parameters so for the
volume the points can go for all of them
you can grade the cells you can give
this a score from one up to 256
points okay
and then based on this
score the cells are going to be plotted
in a histogram so you have here the
volume laser light scatter histogram so
the bottom is one point if you go up it
goes up to 256 points and on the left is
one point and if you go to the right it
goes up to 256 points
and each dot in this histogram is a cell
and the position of this dot the
position of the cell
depends on the score that that cell got
for volume and for laser light scatter
so for example a cell that is further up
in the histogram is a larger cell than a
cell that is lower in the histogram
now
because the position of the cell depends
on the morphology and we know that white
cells leukocytes that all belong to the
same type they're going to have similar
morphology naturally they're going to
create populations so i have here a
green population a pink population and a
blue population and we know that each
one of them represents a subtype of
white cells and then all this one has to
do is count how many dots i have in each
one of these populations and this is my
whiteboard cell count my differential
count
now
you don't need to know the color by
memory to know which population is which
cell type because remember the
morphology directly relates the position
of the dot in the histogram so then we
can basically if i tell you that the
blue population is composed of
lymphocytes i don't have to memorize
that to know it because we know the
lymphocytes are the smallest leukocytes
in the blood and therefore they will be
lowest in the histogram that's because
they are smaller and that's where you
have the lowest volume measurements
by comparison the monocytes are the
largest cells
in their blood and therefore they're
going to go up in the histogram and
that's why they are the green population
and then neutrophils they have more
granularity in the cytoplasm and they
have a more lobated nucleus than a
monocyte and lymphocyte and that's why
they are to the right in the histogram
and they have the pink population here
now how can i use this to detect
morphology
because these measurements this volume
this
light scatter
they we actually measure for each
population the mean volume the mean
light scatter
the mean uh
conductivity and we also measure the
standard deviation for each one of them
and these numbers because they are
directly related to the morphology
they are basically quantitative
measurements of cell size of cell
granularity and of cell nuclear to
cytoplasmic ratio and we can now use the
uh decision rule ability of the
instrument to flag every time a sample
comes where your lymphocytes are too
large you can flank those
or your neutrophils are too large you
can flag those or your neutrophils have
two liter lingual two liter eye laser
light scatter because they're hyper
granular you can flag those as well
and that's therefore we can get the
instrument to do an automated
morphologic check for the laboratory so
basically you can go back to doing what
we should never have stopped doing the
laboratory meaning that every time we
get a blood we will do a count all right
but besides that we will also verify
that this blood does not carry any
morphological abnormality that is
clinically relevant to the clinician we
can verify that and if nothing is wrong
the morphology is all within the normal
expected range for this instrument we
just report all the results and you're
gonna do exactly what you do today
uh you just get a sample a sample of
blood you put an instrument and you
report out the cbc
everything is fine but what is critical
here is that
you
you looked for morphology changes and
and if they were present you would catch
them
and that is a major game changer in the
quality of care that we are providing to
our patients
so as you see uh this is basically with
and with the additional advantages of
the dxh800 we have better resolution the
morphology changes we have better
opportunities to be capturing this
clinically relevant morphologic
abnormalities
now why is this important let's take a
look at let's make a comparison here to
looking at a new parameter okay so for
example we just described the importance
of
neutrophil morphologic changes when a
patient has sepsis
and that is one opportunity that we have
to improve the patient care
now we have other approaches like other
companies which are looking at immature
ground side counting for that and and
where is the problem that we see so for
example look at here at the maturation
of neutrophils they don't go from a
blast to a promyelocyte to a myocyte uh
immediately this is a continuous
maturation
so basically as you can see here uh on
the lower right we have an image i have
three cells here
i don't think i don't think anybody can
confidently say that they are either
neutrophils or
uh
bands you know you have arguments that
could push either way you know you can
say that these are bands because they
are not perfectly separated into loops
but at the same time there is there is a
stricture in the band area so they
basically could also be called
neutrophils it's a really a very
subjective area and why is that
subjective not because you have problems
with technology but because that's how
the biology works right
so
basically you you have here a problem
and and do you think that instruments or
technology can solve that not really
because this is not a limitation of the
technology this is a limitation of
biology
instruments can discriminate a
lymphocyte from a monocyte because in
the human body you do not have a cell
that is intermediate between
a lymphocyte and a monocyte and
israelites can discriminate a neutrophil
from a lymphocyte because we do not have
a cell that is intermediate between that
so when you look at the histogram you
have a valley you have a perfect
separation
between each one of them now if you want
to discriminate a band from a mature
neutrophil here you have our
um pink population which is your myolite
population in the blood it should be
predominantly neutrofused with maybe a
few bands here and there now if i wanted
to identify immature granulocytes those
that are um more immature than bands
right
um i know for a fact that they will go
up in the histogram because they are
larger by default but where do i draw
the line there is no valley here that
perfectly separates your metals and melo
sites from the bands
so
it really becomes very difficult to do
that and what you're seeing is that
those who have tried they end up
creating a new parameter it's very easy
to create a gate
around a portion of this population
count how many dots fall in there and
say hey we have a new parameter image of
gramocides you could have done that for
monocytes for any one of them but the
question is are are we achieving a
better diagnostic performance than what
already exists and when you look at the
literature you will see
that uh these measurements of
subsets of cells that are not perfectly
isolated
they will have just an equivalent
performance to just counting the cells
which is the bottom so here you look at
this histogram and uh on the first look
it feels like you have two histograms
two raw curves but if you look very
carefully there are actually three of
them there is a red one which is the
lower performance rock curve but there
is also two other uh curves a green and
a blue
uh curve here in this image and the
reason they are so difficult to
distinguish from one another is because
they perfectly overlap each other and
when two rock curves overlap that
basically means that the two tests the
two laboratory tests that they represent
are basically the same performance and
there is no reason why it would change
from one to another and what are those
tests the immature granulocytes and the
absolute mutual fuel count so basically
you know the idea of counting subsets
and creating all these new parameters is
not really helping clinicians in
providing they improved patient care
when the real need is actually to go
back in there and make sure that you
capture these morphological changes and
that's what we do with the dx800 we have
the technology to evaluate morphology as
you saw to capture the cell size the
granularity of the cytoplasm the
lobulate of the nucleus and the energy
ratio and we captured this information
but it also gives you here flagging
rules the ability to write decision
rules so that you flag samples that may
have
relevant morphologic changes and that
you would miss if you did not have this
technology
now on top of that what we are also
doing is
after we give the instrument the
ability to flag samples it is also
important to understand
which
patient
gave us the sample so for example a
patient with atypical lymphocytes and we
just described how they look like
they're large they have a lower uh nc
ratio and we just described how the
instrument is capable of flagging those
cases those changes for you
now
once you go to the microscope after you
see this change
the next question once you identify this
who is this patient who is this patient
that is giving me a typical lymphocytes
on the microscope because it might be a
teenager with um
a fever
and uh enlarged lymph nodes on the neck
and then you say well this looks like a
very fractured monoclosis which is a
completely different significance if i
tell you that the same cell is coming
from a patient who is a middle-aged man
who has been treated for a lymphoma now
your differential diagnosis is
completely different and the relevance
for the patient is also different
therefore
the
the identification of the morphology is
part of the big picture but also the
understanding of which the patient is
sending the sample is also part of it
and therefore we have included besides
the decision rules besides the
morphologic information the customer can
also incorporate patient information
into the decision rule they can use the
age of the patient the gender the
location of the patient uh the nuclear
test uh the location of actually the
artery physician the diagnostic code any
patient information that arrives at the
next agent handler instrument can be
used to
to be written in the decision rule so
that for example a laboratory can have a
a
large neutrophil flag which is as you
discussed can indicate an impact
infection but they can choose to use
this
flag only in neonates
when the change is more relevant this
allows the laboratory to have a perfect
um
combination a perfect um balance between
the amount of work they're gonna put
because one of sample is flagged you
have to make a menu review and that's a
lot of work a balance between that
amount of workload versus the quality of
the or patient care that the laboratory
is offering
so really it becomes almost like an
automated hematological consult for
every single patient and this is one
side of how we in batman culture are
using this morphologic feature to
improve patient care and address this
huge need the laboratories have which is
the need to appreciate morphology at the
same time that um
at the same time that a cell count is
being performed
now we have not forgotten that counting
cells is also important and because
cells are identified based on the
morphology we can also tap into the
morphologic features to have a accurate
counting and to minimize the number of
situations where we can have an
interference and that is also thanks to
the new angles of light scatter so
remember we just described how the lh
instruments the pre dxh instruments are
actually in all other instruments in the
market they all will recognize certain
features of cells in our case we
recognize morphology others who
recognize fluorescence or chemical
staining etc but regardless of what
technology was used to recognize certain
features of cells cells must be plotted
in a histogram and it is the position of
the cells in the histogram that is going
to allow the instrument to know what
type of cell you're dealing with
now
a car limitation of all instruments
arise from the fact that they only have
one histogram and if i only have one
histogram i only have one
certain amount of space to place
particles in there and if two different
cell types end up going to the same
position in the histogram the instrument
has no way of knowing that it is either
subway or cell b and i can have problems
there are two things that can happen
here and the tooth are very problematic
for the laboratory you can have a
situation of the instrument with parts
account it doesn't alert you that there
was an interference and then your
problem is that you reported wrong
results and the other problem is that
maybe the instrument was able to detect
that something was off and caught the
abnormality but the problem now is the
fact that you're going to have a lot of
workload to have to make a microscopic
smear have to go into the instrument
data recognize what is happening and
that is also problematic because
laboratories are overstuffed and
underpaid and are having a very big
challenge in addressing the clinical
needs especially if you have to be going
to the microscope and involving manual
labor so many times
so
how can our new histograms help well
they help because if the major
limitation is a physical it's a space
problem i have one histogram and i have
way too many particles way too many
different cell types to plot in that
histogram and i'm telling you that the
dicks age 800 has new angles of light
scatter and the new angles of light
scatter
can be used to create new histograms so
now i have more space basically to plot
cells and we are learning now how this
space has been tremendously available to
isolate different cell types and avoid
interferences so so let's take a look at
some examples here okay
so
this is a very common problem faced by
laboratories the presence of cellular
interference in the white blood cell
counting so what we are seeing here on
the left is a normal histogram we are
going to use impedance to cut white
cells and we start here 35 degrees 35
centiliters
uh on the left here this is when you
start counting white cells and and your
curve should start at the zero area now
on the right where the arrow is you are
seeing that the curve has what we call a
high takeoff
a high takeoff
of the histogram of the curve why is
that because you have particles that are
um just about 35 femtoliters which is
where the measurement starts for
counting whites
and these particles are messing up your
light cell counts they could be there's
so many particles that can fall in this
part of the histogram you can have
nucleated rbcs you can have giant
platelets you can have platelet clamps
you can have even malarial parasites
they all can go in there and you know
what happens up until the dx800 there's
nothing you can do you can just alert
the customer there is a problem and they
have to do the work of figuring out what
happened and cleaning it up
now
thanks to the xh800 and new histograms
we are being able to isolate these
different interfering particles so here
we have giant platelets and as you can
see they can be as large as a white cell
and that's why they're causing cell
interference well
in this histogram here which is a unique
the ex it's one of the new histograms
let's discriminate new histograms from
traditional histogram the traditional
one is the one that every instrument had
before the dx800 is typically one for
size and one for
granularity so we have we had on the lh
analyzers volume versus laser light
scatter alcohol might have forward
fluorescence versus side fluorescence
right in this traditional histogram they
may all fall in the same area but now we
have a new histogram here which is
created by low angle light scatter
against actual light loss and look at
the position of the giant platelets in
this histogram
and let's look at the position of
platelet clamps which is another
abnormality causing exactly this problem
cell interference
in this new histogram they are in a
completely different area
at the same time nucleated red blood
cells also are in a completely different
area as you can see here
therefore we can now count nucleated
reboot cells with much better accuracy
and therefore these cells are not
causing interferences anymore and
they've nucleated in their white cell
counting this means number one that the
accounts being reported by the
instrument are more reliable and the
likelihood of reporting out a a false
leukocytosis because nucleated rats
ended up being counted as whites is
tremendously decreased because of this
optimal detection that we have now
thanks to this new histogram
and and that has been reported out in
the literature but at the same time it
also is allowing us to
to
even if you had an instrument that could
have detected that there was an
instrument uh an interference
now we don't have to work to clean this
interference anymore because the
instrument is already doing that for you
without any additional workload the same
also for parasitized rbcs here you have
a
blood cells with a
malaria parasites in fact in them they
also can cause cell interference but
they also have a completely different
position in the histogram as you can see
here so here we have
on the upper side
we have um one patient and on the bottom
you have a second patient and on the
left you have these patients uh
histograms at the time when they were
diagnosed with malaria and then in the
center during treatment and on the right
to have after treatment and if you look
where the arrows are they are showing is
very small green population so this is
the position of malarially infected
abysses
in this histogram which is completely
different from the position of anab
nucleotide resist which is completely
different from the position of
giant platelets and completely different
from the position of data clamps so now
we can discriminate them all and clean
it for you
another very nice example of desk how
this technology is helping patients is
uh on the reticulocyte counting so let's
go back into how this works so for
example when we are counting writings we
must understand that
inside the hematological analyzer we
don't have only one instrument we
actually have many instruments inside
the same box we call these instruments
chambers so you have a white cell
chamber counting whites and you have a
red cell chamber counting reds and they
have a radical chamber counting writings
and the treatment of blood in different
chambers is different so for the ritik
chamber
we have to actually clean the hemoglobin
of the cells when we're going to
counteratix why because the writings are
differentiated from the reds because
they have remnants of rna in the
cytoplasm and we have to stain these
remnants of rna we use a dye called
supravital dye pneumonia in blue and we
stain the rna remnants and then when we
run this blood in the laser light
scatter the remnants of rna
have caused the stained once cause a
high laser light scatter now in order to
stain them and be able to discriminate
that from other cells we have to
completely clear the hemoglobin from the
cell
and we do that by adding a very light
acid to the blood um this process of
cleaning hemoglobin we call this the
hemoglobinization or the better yet we
have a term which is and ghosting cells
right
we have here on the right you can see
reticulocytes with the little blue dots
in them there's this reticuline this is
basically rna stain the pneumatic bloom
and then you have the pale blue cells
which are ghosted rbcs
now of course when i run this sample on
the right in the laser
your
reticulocytes that have these little
blue dots are gonna have a higher laser
light scatter and that's how we measure
them
but but the problem is
if the ghosting process
failed okay if the cleaning of
hemoglobin did not work well
um i'm gonna end up with cells that are
engosted so they are not reticulocytes
but they have remnants of cytoplasm
hemoglobin in the cytoplasm and
therefore they also have a high laser
right scatter and they end up going
exactly the position of the
reticulocytes
also if you have inclusions on your rbcs
you may have proper harmony
pop and hybrid body bodies you may have
height bodies these are all inclusions
that mean that when you run the cells on
the laser they will also have a high
laser light scatter the result is that
if you go in the literature and you see
if you type in on pubmed pseudo
reticulocytosis
you observe a tremendous number of
papers describing many conditions that
give you a falsely elevated reticulocyte
count as reported by hematological
instruments why is that because the
instruments are basically counting cells
with high laser light scatter and until
the exhibit hundred they had no way of
telling that these cells are not
reticulocytes that they are an unghosted
rbc
now we have the dx800 with multiple
angles of light scatter so let's look at
these four images here
uh the e and don't look at the visuals
okay here we have both density plots and
surface plots
that doesn't matter you can either you
can transform in
the decimal plot here in a surface part
that's not a question the question is
the parameter that is being used
and for these four images the one on the
right the one that is a density plot you
see the parameter is volume versus
light scatter
this is the traditional histogram
and you can see in purple the position
where the reticulocytes go okay
now on the left in the surface plots the
parameters being used to create this
histogram they are not volume and laser
light scatter they are actual light loss
which is one angle flat scatter against
upper middle angular scatter which is
another end of light scatter so this is
basically one of the new
histograms that are unique to the dx800
technology so note that you are seeing a
population of yellow
cells yellow dots that you can see
in a clearly different position
from the purple dots
they are different in the new histogram
but when you go to the traditional
histogram the volume laser light scatter
you can see that they are exactly in the
area where you expect reticulocytes to
be
now thanks to this having this new
histogram we now can isolate
true reticulocytes that are here dotted
in purple and you can see them here
from this unghosted cells that are
causing interference and because we can
isolate them we can remove them
from the counting of reticulocytes and
therefore
in this technology we are not having
cellular reticulocytosis we are
reporting an accurate rhythmic count
even in the presence of this common
interference substances and and that is
basically telling the laboratory that
you have to go to the microscope fewer
times you have less workload and most
importantly importantly you have an
accurate result and it will not report
out to a clinician a highly elevated
ready count
when the patient does not have that
and and this is really critical
so you have a reliable count in the
process of abnormalities
so again basically the key message i
think is that laboratory hematology is
more than counting cells
um and and the major limitation of
modern day laboratory hematology is not
lack of parameters it's not lack of new
counts of cells especially if you have
new accounts that are not are not
providing an improved performance
demonstrated by rockers the major
limitation of modern laboratory
hematology is the fact that we are no
longer appreciating the morphology
and and we need to change the game and
we have now an instrument that is
looking at the cells for you at the same
time that it is counting them and we
just need to use this uh technology to
improve our patient care and not allow
and without having an increase in
workload and labor costs
thank you so much and i'll i'll be happy
to take any questions thank you
you dr chavez
if you have questions please feel free
to submit them at this time
okay there's there are no questions in
our queue
so that will conclude our presentation
thank you for attending and enjoy the
rest of the conference
you